do you want a better believe nation
community so I got an email recently
from one of my loyal youtube subscribers
love you guys trisha and sure it in to
say this hello Evan have been watching
her videos and I'm hooked on to them I
watch them every day is a part of my
brownie ritual Thank You Trisha it was a
Herculean task for me to find
like-minded people in my city my family
is very supportive in my endeavors but I
think having a support system in the
city or same nation works even better is
there a way we could have subscribers to
your videos as a group or community so
we could make more friends I was not
sure if one already exists but if I
didn't it would be great to have one
thanks again kudos to you regards Trisha
so in general I love this idea i love
this rule i think most people's
environments do hold them back i think
most people don't have a good enough
support system and I think that's why
the videos are so helpful right i mean i
made these videos because I wanted to be
surrounded by people who are thinking
bigger than i was at the time insta lem
here's where i struggle i'm not sure the
execution of this you know i love
believe nation I love you guys
participating in the comments I think we
have done a really good job on this
channel of having a really positive
community for the most part most of the
comments are really positive and
supportive which is great it's a
testament to you guys watching and what
you believe in I know a lot of
friendships and collaborations have
happened off of youtube and even on
YouTube from you guys being in the
comments I don't know how to execute an
offline strategy or you know here's
somebody in your city is that something
to be helpful interesting what would the
execution look like I'm open to ideas if
it's something that can help
entrepreneurs grow I'm obviously all in
favor of it I love the idea of fans
meeting up and connecting with each
other whenever I travel I always send an
email out to my newsletter to say hey
I'm coming through this city your city
would you like to meet up and grab a
coffee I just don't know about how to
properly execute this idea of you guys
connecting with each others but I like
it so if you guys are open to it if
there's an easy way to do it leave a
comment below because I'm curious to
know what your thoughts are and again if
it's something that can help you guys
and help entrepreneurs out then I
all for it so share your thoughts leave
a comment below I'll join the discussion
as usual thank you again for all your
feedback for your loyalty if your
viewership I really appreciate it and it
just speaks to what a special community
that we've created here on youtube so
thank you guys so much